This is a reminder, again.
Let's look inside a camera.
We've looked at this image before.
This is a film camera with film here, the optics and the lens here, the mirror
that moves away when the shutter is released, and that hits the film, and of
course the, the prism that let's you see exactly what are you going to capture.
So light goes in this way, and the mirror, depending on when I
press the shutter, moves up and then of course it hits the sensor.
And of course, what we now need to figure out is how big the opening would be
here, and also how long do we keep this shutter open to get
the light in at the appropriate level to get the picture we want.
Here I'm basically showing you another schematic of a camera.
And again, in this instance, it's again an SLR camera.
This is the lens assembly.
And here you notice, the lens is basically a bunch of different types of lenses.
It could be a mixture of concave and
convex lenses with the purpose of basically kind of focusing the light
towards where we want the image sensor to get the best information.
So this is the size of the aperture that would let the right kind of
light in here.
This is the shutter.
Opens and closes when we press the shutter release on a camera.
Again, it'll basically be open for a specific time.
The aperture, of course,
would be open all the time at different size to let the kind of light in.
This is the only device that will control amount of light that hits the sensor.
So the shutter will only open and
close to get the right kind of light on to the sensor.
Here you see an example of the mirror going up.
When the mirror moves up, of course, all the light goes and hits the sensor.
And above is where the whole eyepiece pentaprism is, to make sure that we can
see exactly what's actually going to hit the sensor after the mirror moves up.